we begin with breaking news overnight
there was a dramatic end to the
manhattan manhunt rather for an alabama
inmate and the corrections official
accused of helping him escape police
cornered casey white and vicki white no
relation after a 15-minute car chase in
evansville indiana casey white an
accused murderer surrendered authorities
say that vicki white shot herself in the
head she later died from that injury
chris davis of our national affiliate
that's wtvf is outside the sheriff's
office in evansville with more on this
story christmas was an amazing end to
the story that the country was watching
good morning to you
good morning gail quite the story indeed
this search lasted nearly two weeks we
spoke to a deputy with the u.s marshals
service who leads the investigation he
shared new details about how these two
were finally caught
casey quickly surrendered and his
immediate words to our team was is
please help my wife
she just shot herself in the head u.s
marshals say there is no evidence casey
and vicki white were ever married but
their capture brings a stunning end to a
manhunt that captivated the country for
nearly two weeks
law enforcement collided with their
third getaway car a gray cadillac in
evansville indiana u.s deputy marshal
chad hunt is the commander of the gulf
coast regional fugitive task force
there's several tragedies you know to
this story the way this escape ended but
also too it's things that somebody
entrusted with what she was given as a
correctional officer planned organized
and facilitated this escape vicki white
died in the hospital hours later it all
started on april 29th authorities say
this surveillance video shows officer
white leading the inmate to her patrol
car outside the jail in lauderdale
county alabama
police say they ditched it for this 2007
ford edge which she allegedly bought
under an alias it was found abandoned in
tennessee last week
before the duo was caught in indiana a
tip led the marshal service to release
these images surveillance photos of a
man they believed to be casey white at
an evansville car wash last tuesday they
say he abandoned that vehicle a 2006
ford f-150 there visiting with the car
wash owner and some additional
surveillance footage
that led us to believe that they were in
this great cadillac
from there deputy marshall hunt says law
enforcement swept the area for that car
they found it at a nearby hotel where
vicki white was spotted wearing a wig as
she left with casey white monday that
discovery turned into a 15-minute chase
that culminated in their capture nearly
300 miles from the jail they fled
together
back in alabama lauderdale county
sheriff rick singleton made this promise
about casey white
he's not getting out of this jail again
i'll assure you that
now as for casey white he's expected to
face capital murder charges later this
month back in alabama as for vicki's
death it poses a question that we may
never truly get an answer to how does a
suspected murderer with a criminal past
convince a corrections director in good
standing to help him escape tony
that is the big question chris davis
from our nashville affiliate wtvf chris
thank you very much we were all
following this story i don't think
anybody felt it was going to have a
happy ending nobody felt that but it's
just i'm with chris davis i want to know
there's so many answers to this story
that we may never know the answer
unfortunately it all goes away with with
vicky uh what was she thinking what was
she doing mm-hmm
tragic ending hard she's gonna take her
life at the very end yeah i know and him
describing her as his wife yeah which is
an interesting development questions
there